for 31 years I have been acting in major
motion pictures in TV series but you may
not recognize my face
I'm Doug Jones I am an actor I got into
acting out of a need almost to be
validated and it was at Ball State
University that I discovered the art of
mine it's a very visual form of
communication and entertainment little
did I know that this would be early
training ground for the career that I
was going to have lay in later years I
had no idea after moving out to
Hollywood land in March of 1985 and
thinking okay now's the time to pursue
this acting thing
my fourth booking was for a McDonald's
campaign that got me kind of hooked into
oh he's that tall skinny guy who wears
stuff and moves well in it and doesn't
complain while doing so my first feature
film was Batman Returns I got that
auditioned because of my contorted legs
and the credits that says thin clown
which kind of kind of self-descriptive
isn't it I have been in over 150
productions that would include
everything from feature films like hocus
pocus Hubley one Hellboy to the Golden
Army the fawn in Pan's Labyrinth was a
page turning career moment for me
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
I played the Silver Surfer Star Trek
discovery as commander surreal and most
recently in the shape of water so when
asked about how long is a make up take
it depending on the creature it can be
anything from a suit going on and
zipping up the back or a makeup that is
applied you from head to toe for
instance as commander surreal and Star
Trek discovery it's around two hours a
day which is mercifully short flip-side
would be an Abe Sapien from the Hellboy
movies so that's one of the longer ones
that took seven hours a day
wearing rubber bits that gets everything
that you think it would be it is hot
want to be it is heavier than you want
it to be it's more isolating than you
want it to be you can't always make it
access to your naughty bits to go pee if
you want why go through all of this
makeup application the time that it
takes you can create monsters with the
effects now I think people like to watch
other people so even if that person is
playing a monster they want to connect
with a human's interpretation and
performance of that monster it's
old-school cinema magic I kind of get
the best of both worlds when it comes to
being a public celebrity the bigger
movies I've been in and the bigger
things that I'm known for I look like
this and on the street
I'm just the tall skinny guy that's a
gift now that I'm in a movie like the
shape of water with 13 Oscar nominations
I'm getting recognized in public a
little bit more but it's still not to
the point where I where I have people
hiding in my bushes hoping to get a
snapshot at me topless that's not
happening again
[Music]